I don't know it feels old hat now I mean
you know it's another year you got
another Emmy whatever no no this is so
exciting it feels good I mean you know
I'm not gonna lie that I like coming up
there and and I don't know I feel like
when you don't think that you're gonna
win it makes it even more I'm happy to
just be part of invited to the dance but
when you get the prom queen crown it's
it's kind of cool you just some get
DirecTV back on at the house so he could
see them don't know my phone has been
blowing up I don't know so yeah I guess
yeah he's singing oh okay
Ian you're on Entertainment Tonight
right now Ian did you get the TV working
at home I didn't so where did you watch
I did not watch so my sister called him
and let him know yeah Wow so he heard
from somebody in the family yes oh all
right bye I love you I love you I love
you
that is awesome
um just want to ask you real quick you
played two very diverse characters what
did that mean to you to win with two
very diverse women I mean it's it's even
more special because it's two totally
different stories that like I said up
there I mean we're you have an
opportunity to be a part of a
conversation as we're expressing our art
and it's it's special expression I'm a
little speechless
now edge elation give me hug
double Emmy winner
you